today on the matt walsh show there are
10 million jobs open in this country
right now because employers are finding
it impossible to coax the unemployed off
of their couches i want to talk about
this crisis and it is a crisis and also
share some of the stories from these
business owners so that we can all
understand what they're up against if
you think that our country has an
entitlement problem wait until you hear
this also an
elementary school in atlanta is under
fire for instating racial segregation
they literally had black classrooms and
white classrooms plus larry elder is
running for governor of california he's
a reliable conservative very outspoken
which is why his answer about trans
bathrooms was a little bit surprising
and disappointing and the health chief
down in australia has warned the people
of that country that they must avoid all
conversation in public because
conversation can be deadly now i hate
small talk as much as the next guy
but this seems to be overboard we'll get
into that and much more today on the mat
wall street
you may have heard that uh something
truly unprecedented is happening in our
country right now there are at present
over 10 million jobs available 10
million open jobs a number higher than
anything we've ever seen before cnbc has
more on this they report quote the
number of job openings in the u.s
economy jumped more than 10 million in
june the highest on record as the u.s
labor market continues a choppy recovery
from last year's economic shutdowns
there were 10.1 million open jobs on the
final day of june the report said up
from 9.2 million in may
economists polled by dow jones were
expecting 9.1 million openings the jump
came as the quits rate increased while
the layoffs and discharges rate was
unchanged reflecting increased
bargaining power and employment options
for workers by industry leisure and
hospitality show one of the highest
levels of job openings at more than 1.6
million health care and social
assistance has 1.5 million openings so
those are the june numbers just now
coming in it's probably even higher at
present the problem of course
a potentially cataclysmic problem is
that many of these jobs are open because
the companies with those openings are
simply unable to fill them
as of may this year over 40 percent of
small business owners reported that they
were unable to find workers find enough
workers that is that was back when we
had a then record
8.1 million open positions
seems very likely that the number is now
well over 50 percent
and that's just for the companies that
officially qualify as small businesses
right
there's no doubt an incre incongruity
here because
while all these millions of businesses
are not able to find people to perform
the tasks necessary to continue
operating properly and normally
there are right now
13 million people collecting
unemployment checks 10 million of them
are specifically collecting from one of
the three pandemic unemployment
programs established back in march of
2020. all three of those programs are
supposed to end in september but that
assumes that congress won't extend them
and my guess is that congress will
extend them just as the eviction
moratorium was extended and the pause on
student loan payments was extended
what all of this means together is that
many americans millions we can assume
are collecting unemployment
not paying their rent
not paying their student loans on top of
the stimulus payments they received
all while they're surrounded by
companies
begging them to come work
now i was curious about those companies
i mean what is it like to run a business
in this climate
a climate unlike anything we've seen
before
where all of your potential workers are
on the taxpayer dole
suckling on the teat as it were
latched on and refusing to let go what
is that like
the media is not going to highlight
these stories just as they weren't
interested in highlighting the stories
of property owners who are having their
property stolen from them by the cdc
so just as in that case i will highlight
them myself i put this question out
there on twitter yesterday and have
received
hundreds of responses from business
owners or people who are in charge of
hiring for their companies
i think some of these answers are quite
revealing and worth reading so
let's go through them and see what they
all have in common it gives you a good
kind of and these are different kinds of
of jobs from all across the country
gives you good good sort of
cross-section to look at
so let's read some of these
um the first says i have three job
openings for custodial work paying 15 an
hour which i think is fair and i live in
missouri which is a low-cost state
applicants have been demanding 25 at the
minimum which is ridiculous for that
kind of work
another says i'm in the construction
rental business we cannot hire mechanics
drivers or sales people i'm an inside
sales guy we've had one applicant this
year who got the job by default he
wasn't even smart enough to get clean
piss and fail and failed his drug test
were so short staffed our sustainer
service is minimal at best because of
that fact we can't hire we have four
open positions and have had them for
months no applicants at all
another says third generation
construction business in northwest
indiana demand is way up due to people
flooding outside of chicago but there
are no workers willing to work
construction we offer health insurance
and 401k but that's not incentive enough
we just do not have anyone calling for
jobs we're booked up for months and
contractors are willing to wait because
everyone is in the same boat another
says i have tried to interview 30 people
that have applied for a job they just
don't show up for the interviews pay is
never a reason because we don't even get
that far the ones that i i have that
i've been able to hire and show up have
poor attendance and work ethic it's
brutal i could hire two or three people
right now i've been trying for three
months
other people i know are in the same
position
another says we own a small cafe we
cannot get people to work they apply
then don't show up for the interview we
believe the application is just to show
that they're trying for unemployment if
they do show they want crazy money and
other perks unheard of in the industry
it is across the board in this industry
restaurants are closing because they
can't hire workers our kitchen is closed
it's insane
another says we've been hiring physical
therapists and ergonomists for our team
we pay 50 to 70 75 an hour so the pay
has never been the issue
but so many of the applicants are cold
rude arrogant just plain not nice
my wife owns slash operates the business
and she has interviewed multiple people
that have zero self awareness not to
mention the interviewees that get upset
because the business caters to women and
of course there's no such thing as
gender
another says family business employs
over a thousand people worst labor
market we've ever seen hard to find
applicants scary how many can't pass a
drug test work ethic and society is
collapsing demand for remote work are
getting unrealistic
another says one candidates are not
applying at all too a lot of candidates
i talk to have not worked in a year or
close to it and they disclose that they
have not worked because they've been on
unemployment and since unemployment has
stopped they're now looking for work
which is a candidate i would not want to
hire three i'm in the industry uh
entry-level pay in my industry entry
level pays 13 to 14 an hour a lot of
candidates are wanting 16 to 18 an hour
and companies i work with simply don't
want to pay that or are having to pay
higher wages for entry-level help
another says my family has a
distribution business in the automotive
sector it's been very difficult getting
people to apply for 15
an hour jobs and even more difficult
getting applicants to show up after
phone interviews then if we get lucky
enough to get a warm body with a pulse
to show up for the job and we hire them
on the spot these new hires ghost us 50
of the time we're revamping our comp
programs throughout as we scale out the
season and i will be giving
discretionary bonuses to those who
earned it during our peak season making
every effort to retain those that keep
the engine running another says we have
two units in memphis and i just closed
out one to one of the two to consolidate
the staff next to no one is applying we
moved from 12 an hour to 15 an hour in
the kitchen servers make 250 to 300 per
shift but still call out on a regular
basis we had four call outs last friday
and five on saturday we're now skeleton
at our original unit we have no idea how
long it will be before we can find
enough staff to reopen our second unit
very few staff end up working their full
schedule not one restaurant is fully
staffed the hotel across the street only
uses
uh 200 of 450 rooms during the week and
304 450 on the weekend due to lack of
staff
and another says my husband owns a
painting company pays 20 an hour
starting the only workers he can find
wanted to be paid under the table so
they wouldn't lose unemployment
okay
i could go on and on i mean hundreds of
stories like this that's just in my
inbox
across the country there are millions of
similar tales and they all have
certain common threads which connect
them
candidates don't want to lose their
government welfare that's the first
priority
um they often make outrageous demands
they make little effort during the
interview process and even less when
they're hired and lots of people can't
be bothered to lay off the drugs long
enough to pass the drug test
clear to most thinking people
that and another thing too by the way
you notice there a lot of these jobs are
paying 15 an hour now we were told 15 an
hour that's the magic number it's a
living wage and everyone deserves 15 an
hour
a lot of these places they're paying 15
and they still can't find people willing
to do the jobs
pay 20 an hour still can't find people
to do it
so it's clear to most thinking people
that the immediate culprit and cause of
this crisis are the government
entitlements which have been which have
given otherwise healthy and capable
people the option
to simply do nothing
attaching themselves instead to the
taxpayer ship like barnacles
there are of course people who you know
fall on hard times and need help
there were millions of people during the
pandemic who lost their jobs because of
action taken by the state
and that's all one thing right that's
one category
but living off of the dole should not be
an available lifestyle choice it should
not be a permanent or indefinite option
that anyone can avail themselves of even
when they could easily find a job
it's one thing for there to be a
temporary resource to fall back on in a
moment of dire need and that's the way
these programs were originally sold to
us if you were dumb enough to believe
that that's all it would ever be
it's another thing when an able-bodied
person can elect
can make the conscious choice
to be a non-contributor sustaining
himself through the efforts of
contributors
our system has always allowed
far too much of that kind of thing but
with the extra welfare programs put in
place during the pandemic the problem
has grown to catastrophic proportions
businesses are now having to shut down
because again they cannot coax the
unemployed off of their couches
but the problem runs deeper than that
you know it's one thing for the
government to have these insane suicidal
policies in place it's another thing
to have a populist so eager to take
advantage of them i mean
the sickness at the root here is
whatever has made so many people willing
to live this way
whatever has made this lifestyle seem
appealing
because a healthy well-adjusted mature
right-minded adult would not want to sit
around for a year doing nothing not
paying his rent not working a job
such an adult would prefer to work for a
living than to be pampered by the
government so the real problem is that
there are fewer and fewer of those kinds
of adults
many people are satisfied to be
unproductive to avoid any and all work
to live a life that requires no effort
floating along aimlessly going nowhere
i mean it's one thing to live like that
upon retirement and even then it can
drive you mad with boredom
but to live like that at the age of 25
having never contributed anything
having achieved nothing
having not even tried to achieve
anything
that's another thing entirely
a healthy society would find few takers
for such a life
given that it is so fundamentally
despairing and pointless and dull and
empty
but that's not the case for us
for many people this is what they want
it's what they desire
which is to say they desire really
nothing
but not in austere humble nothing rather
an entitled
expensive nothing
that they expect you to pay for
and that i think is the real sickness
now let's get to our five headlines
you know i really want to tell you guys
about rock auto you know the thing about
rock out probably i've never mentioned
before
is that it makes it so that you do not
have to go to the auto parts store which
nobody wants to do that when it's really
hot out or really at any time uh why do
that why go through that whole rigmarole
as the kids would say when you could
just stay at your house or be wherever
you're gonna be and pull out your phone
go to rockauto.com always offers the
lowest prices possible they're not gonna
change uh the prices they're also you
know this is about giving you the lowest
possible price which means that when you
go to rockauto.com um you you know you
don't have to shop anywhere else that's
the best price you're gonna get and
they're a family business they've been
doing this online for 20 years and go to
rockauto.com to shop for auto body parts
from hundreds of manufacturers the
catalog is unique
very easy to navigate you can quickly
see all the parts that are available for
your car truck you can also you can also
choose the brand specifications and
prices you prefer which makes it a lot
easier as well to browse through rock
auto and find what you want than going
and walking aimlessly around so go to
rockauto.com right now and see all the
parts available for your car truck and
write walsh in there how did you hear
about us box so they know that we sent
you
you know one of my favorite things uh
about little kids is the way that they
question things well that could be my
favorite thing and also my least
favorite thing it depends on the
questions they're asking and how many
times they ask the same question in the
context and everything
um but
the good thing with kids is their minds
are always working and they're trying to
figure stuff out
and um you never know what exactly is
going on up there until they open their
mouths as my four-year-old did last
night while he was sitting on the couch
and um
and he he turned to me and he asked
pointing to his older brother he said
daddy
if me and luke switched heads
what would happen
and i said
well i mean you die first of all so
don't that's the first thing and you
probably make a heck of a mess in the
process so and he kind of goes silent
and he thinks about it and then i start
thinking about it too
and now i'm now i'm now
my
wheels are turning and then i i asked
him i said well okay
what if you did switch heads with him
would you
now have luke's body or luke's head like
would would giving your head to luke
mean that you go with your head
or would it be more accurate to say that
you remain with your body and now you
just have luke's head you see what i'm
saying
very philosophical question and um
and he processed it for a while
and eventually we both agreed that he
would probably travel with his head but
it's an interesting question
and then later on when i was putting him
to bed and we're still talking about
this question of uh removing heads and
everything great thing to talk about at
bedtime
and you know and things are finally
clicking and he goes wait a second daddy
so so i'm in my head
i'm in my bones in my head and he starts
knocking on his head like he's knocking
on the front door trying to communicate
with himself
and then we got it when we started
talking about the mind body problem and
neurology and the soul and it was all
very metaphysical after a while
um i say we were talking about that but
it was like i was talking and he was
just sitting there not understanding
anything i was saying but i did make
sure to emphasize
putting all that aside
don't actually try to do this please do
not try to take your head off
that's all that should be the main point
here
all right um
before we get into the the big stories i
do want to show you this quickly at the
top here uh now that cuomo has resigned
the people of new york are speaking out
and i thought that i saw this being
passed around on social media i thought
this was interesting here's a clip of
just some average citizens in new york
sharing their thoughts about the news
uh and i thought they raised a number of
good points and they do so really
eloquently and so let's check that out
that cuomo
said we couldn't be outside last year
where are we at
what is your message to cuomo right now
rotten hell you son of a [ __ ] you put
pineapple on your pizza and you get no
you're next de blasio you're [ __ ]
next you're next we're on yours boy we
or union square promo don't you get away
when i see you i'm gonna grab you by
your [ __ ] neck we're replacing cuomo
with
bobby schmurder
bobby for salvador
[Applause]
they make a good point
they really do
um
that uh
apparently
cuomo is
not popular in new york i guess we can
summarize it that way
all right let's uh well i don't think we
need to analyze that anymore than we
already have here's a report from wsb in
atlanta about actual racial segregation
in a public school in the city this is
the local news report uh it's a little
bit long it's a couple minutes but i
think it's worth watching also when we
play lawn clips it gives me a chance to
drink coffee that's the real reason we
do this but let's watch this go ahead
we've lost sleep
trying to figure out like why would a
person do this
kyla posey says she was stunned when she
learned about classes segregated by race
at mary elementary last year a practice
she says was put in place and condoned
by principal sharon briscoe first
it was
just disbelief that i was having this
conversation in 2020 with
a person that looks just like me a black
woman it's segregating classrooms
you cannot segregate classrooms it's
you can't deal with it posey says she
found out the school was putting black
students in two separate classes with
two separate teachers the white kids
were placed in six classes with six
different teachers the parent says she
found this out when she let briscoe know
she wanted her child placed in the
classroom of a teacher she thought would
be a good fit posey says the principal
said that wouldn't work she said that
that's not one of the black classes and
i immediately said what does that mean
i was confused
i asked for more clarification
i was like we have those in the school
and she proceeded to say that yes i have
decided that
i'm going to place all of the
black students in two classes posey says
she insisted her child be placed in a
class with white students she says
briscoe explained her child would be
isolated and i explained to her she
shouldn't be isolated or punished
because i'm unwilling to go along with
your illegal and unethical practice
the poses recorded a call with an
assistant principal where they
complained about the segregated classes
the administrator confirmed it was the
principal's decision and seemed to offer
an explanation why the classes were set
up this way
and then some of them are in a class
because of the services that they need
uh
we'd like to say that this is shocking
actual racial segregation in the
classroom it's about the most illegal
thing
the most one of those fundamentally
illegal things a school could possibly
do
is uh to racially segregate their
classrooms
and actually call them there was no
attempt to hide it it wasn't like they
came up with different labels for this
and oh it just so happens
that it worked out racially in this way
no it's like that's our black class and
this is our white class right
um
we'd like to call that shocking i don't
think we really can i mean we we have
gone
full circle
and
we're back to this now
racial segregation sort of approached
from the opposite direction now though
where now it's a matter of we're going
to segregate because we're trying to get
the white kids away
racial segregation in the jim crow era
was the other way
we don't we don't want we don't want the
white people to have to deal with the
black people so we're going to put them
over there
now it's just that in the reverse
and i say reverse which isn't to say
that it's reverse racism because of
course there's only one kind of racism
if you're
a person and you and you uh think the
people of another race are inferior
and then that makes you racist matter
what race you are
but this is the reverse approach to
racial segregation reverse from what it
was
you know 100 years ago um
and
so that that's not a surprise this is
the direction we've been headed
they've been doing this kind of thing in
in universities and in college
colleges for a while now
maybe not that
explicit like we're gonna have a white
class in a black class but
well we're gonna have a black only space
where but you know black people can get
together or people of color by poc can
all get together and we don't want white
people intriguing on that space we've
been doing stuff like that in colleges
for a while now
so this is where it's headed the if
there's anything sort of surprising here
um
it's that the principal
again made no no attempt to hide it
and so she assumed that everybody was
okay with it
the mother talking to the principal and
the principal says oh yeah it's our
black class
and the mother has to say
what what the what now
my black class what's the problem with
that
and based on this report now maybe there
were other parents who were upset but it
it if if there were
it's they seem to be in the minority
it's mainly this mother who's objecting
which means either
the other parents didn't care and were
on board with it
or they never heard about it
i don't know which would be more
disturbing there could be some
combination of the two
that tells you something about public
school that's why i'm always harping on
this you send your kid into a government
building for seven eight hours a day
you're not gonna know everything that
you're not gonna know almost anything
that happens you're only gonna know what
your kid tells you and especially when
they're younger they're not gonna tell
you a whole hell of a lot
yeah i get home from school and i i get
home from work
and i sit down with my kids i always ask
them
what you do today how'd it go like i
want to hear about their day
and uh
they never have a whole lot to say like
they'll they'll home in on one little
detail
like yesterday i came home i asked them
how to go today and the only thing they
told them they're very excited to tell
me but the only thing they told me about
was that they found a deer skull
in uh in a creek near our house which is
very exciting for kids i don't i don't
blame it but that's the only event from
the day and everything was about the
deer skull
for a kid that's the only thing that
matters right
so when i hear from parents and they say
oh you know as long as you're in
in a conversation with your kids and you
have an open line of dialogue you don't
have to worry about it because they're
going to tell you what's going on and
no they're not
when they're very young they're not
going to
the things that you know are important
and that you'd like to hear about they
don't know that that's important
i think the kids who are racially
segregated they don't understand they
don't know the history of this
of racial segregation in the school they
don't see a problem with it they might
not even told their parents
so things that you know are important
your kids don't know that so they might
not tell you
and then as kids get a little bit older
and even if they do know that
something's important they might not
want to tell you
because they don't want you causing a
stink about it and all these other
things
and also they're being conditioned by
the school to think that these things
are okay
so you can't rely on that
another argument for well it's an
argument for homeschooling as always
also an argument for for uh for
cameras in the classroom
so that you could actually see that
happening when they segregate the
classrooms by race
as we come full circle back to racial
segregation
this is
a tool
you know race
any kind of
tribalism
is is a tool for those in power
a very effective tool as we've seen
to manipulate and exploit and control
people
and um
it has proven this this this tool has
proven
far too alluring
to those who are in power now
from the federal government all the way
down to the school systems
it's far too alluring
so they're exploiting it
there was there was a
what we now have to call unfortunately a
brief moment in time in this hist in in
in history
that i can remember
going back to when i was a in school in
the 90s
where we had something like racial
harmony it wasn't perfect
nothing is ever going to be perfect in a
human society but it was
as perfect as you could hope for it to
be probably
where race was was
not something that i remember talking
about or focusing on as a kid we didn't
talk about it much in school
we were all kids going to school didn't
really think much about it you notice
the differences you don't think about
you don't dwell on it
you don't see anything particularly
significant about it
and that was the state of affairs for
you know a couple decades maybe
until the powers that be said no this is
a tool that is
way too useful
and now we're going back to how it was
before
okay next we have larry elder who's a
well-known conservative talk show host
and author and commentator he's running
for governor in california i like larry
elder i should tell you i admire larry
elder
um
and i was excited to hear that he was
running for governor
much better option than caitlyn jenner
which
isn't saying much admittedly but still
and i i was happy about that
but i am not happy about this and i do
not like or admire this here's his
answer when he's asked by someone about
uh the trans bathroom issue and here's
what he says um so let me just make this
personal for a second my sister is
transgender she's lived her life as a
woman for many years now so would you
not allow her to use uh the woman's
restroom
uh if she is a uh estimated a transition
from being a male to a female
a a transition uh that has been done by
uh by whatever medical uh
intervention there is i see no reason
why she ought not be able to use
whatever bathroom she identifies as
well as long as they've as long as
they've medically transitioned
then of course
now you could say he's running for
governor of california he's got to play
the game a little bit and he's got to
toe the line
um
but i don't buy that
also trying to draw a line here doesn't
make any sense at all
like either
this is just determined biologically or
it's not
either we're determining determining men
and women biologically or we aren't
and if you're going to say well if you
get the surgery then you're a woman
well that means that that biology has
nothing to do with it why even get the
surgery who cares if you have it
what does a surgery mean
okay not to get too graphic but in the
surgery
um if when a man quote unquote becomes a
woman or in in the in the parlance now
is affirmed as a woman um what they are
doing is they are
mutilating his male genitals
to form the
visual approximation
of of what a uh what what the the female
genitals look like
that's it
that that doesn't make you a woman it
doesn't make you any closer to a woman
okay it does not does not bridge that
gap even a little bit you have not you
have not built even
you know
any part of the bridge because you can't
the chasm there is a chasm between man
and woman and it is impossible to cross
over it you can't
you can stay on your part of the chasm
kind of looking over to the people on
the other side
and try to make yourself outwardly look
like them but you're still on that side
and you'll never get to the other
that's what i would say anyway as
someone who believes in science and
truth either that either what i'm saying
is correct or not
and if it's not who cares about the
surgery
which is why we're seeing
the the other side of this equation the
trans activist that's the direction this
is going
where they are de-emphasizing surgery
more and more not to say you shouldn't
get it go ahead and get it if you want
but it doesn't matter if you do
like we used to define this it used to
be you were a pre-op um
transsexual or a post-op
and if you hadn't had the surgery yet
then you're pre-op
it would just kind of assume that that's
that's that's what you're gonna do
that's part of being
of having that identity
now it's who cares
you can maintain all of the normal
physical features of man you can keep
dressing like a man you can look like a
man selling it doesn't matter but you'd
still be a woman
so this line in the sand he's trying to
draw here is just that it's a line in
the sand it can easily be erased
there's nothing firm and or solid here
and he's also using the preferred
pronouns saying she and her in referring
to a male
um
if that is what is required
to be the governor of california then
it's not worth being the governor of
california
if in order to get a republican in as
the governor of california
we need to adopt the left's
um
the left's view of of sex
and biology then we then it's it's not
worth it
what we have to give up
it's not proportional
so we give up our grasp of reality and
we say to them okay you're right about
this really fundamental issue
and as the reward
we get to have a republican governor of
california for a few years
how does that work
i mean long-term
what's the long-term benefit of that how
does that trade work
i'll tell you something the left will
they'll take that trade all day
they'll still oppose any republican runs
for
for governor but they'll take that trade
sure you're gonna give us you're gonna
you're gonna give us the truth you're
gonna give up truth for us
and you get to have a republican
governor of california for a few years
until they're replaced by a democrat
which eventually they will be
the republican governor california by
the way who can't really do anything
because no one else is on his side he's
he is still overseeing a
a estate that has gone completely insane
and his ability to
hold back the tide of insanity is very
very limited and even if he can do it he
is only holding back the tide he's not
stopping it or reversing it he can't do
that
it's not worth the trade
and i and i've gotten to a point now
like i said i like larry elder admire
him but i
uh
this is this is not this is not
tolerable
as a conservative you need to hold the
line on this or what use are you to us
if you're going to give this up
but every day it's another person
it really it really feels like invasion
of the body snatchers in more ways than
one
you wake up and another person who you
have known or at least known of you
thought you knew you thought you knew
what they were about you look at them
and they've got this look in their eyes
and you're like what happened to you
we lost you too
what is going on every day it's another
what was once a firm and reliable
conservative standing up there using
preferred pronouns saying she and her in
reference to males
very sad situation okay um i want to
here's a clip of a of a
school board member in oklahoma
and i want to play this for you because
after my experience at the school board
here in nashville yesterday
um
i have realized that what you're about
to hear here is not
uh an outlier
because this is exactly the kind of
thing i heard as i sat there in the
school board meeting listening to one
pro mask parent after another get up
there
i heard a stuff exactly like this almost
verbatim over and over and over again
let's take a listen to this
i think if anybody's going to flee to
virtual school it needs to be the
masculist i don't think any parent with
a with an asthmatic six-year-old
eight-year-old or 12-year-old
should have to make that choice that
their child can't go to school because
some other kid is going to spread a germ
that could kill them
just goes all over me
i would like to find a way to stand up
as a district
and get our surrounding superintendents
to stand up with us and protect our
little kids
it's insane
to send five and six and seven and eight
all the way up through 11 year olds that
don't have a choice about vaccine
to sit in a classroom
where people can spread a deadly disease
and not even know they're sick
and not even know that in three days
they're going to be sick but they're
spreading it today
because they that's the way it works
this disease
just makes me furious that we're in this
position
if i were a parent of a young child i
didn't know what i would do
but i don't think we should put our
parents in that position
and if there's any way between now and
the beginning of school that we can get
this changed
i hope we can because it's just not okay
for kids to commit murder by coming to
school without a mask
commit
murder
by coming to school without a mask
it would already be irrational and
incorrect to say that oh a kid coming to
school without a mask poses a potential
threat or danger
that's already
way overboard and not true and not
correct
for all the reasons that i have have
given about the reality of cova and its
effect on kids which is very very
minimal
um
but now we're saying oh they they're
they are murderers accusing the kids of
being murderers for not covering their
faces
i think that school board member did
apologize
uh and try to backtrack a little bit
realizing that her phrasing is
is shocking to any rational person
but she said what she said and she
believes it
and like i said i
i heard almost this verbatim no one used
the word murder in reference to the kids
but i i did hear things like your kid's
going to kill my kid if they don't wear
a mask very very very similar
without the word murder being used
we talk about segregation in the schools
and tribalism and how those empower it
it's it is so alluring to to
divide people by tribes and because it's
much more it's much easier to exploit us
that way
well this is another version of it
another version of segregation the
masked and the unmasked
vaccinated and unvaccinated
and the unmasked unvaccinated they are
now
the cause of all of society's problems
they are murderers they are directly
killing you they're a threat to your
children they're gonna murder your
children
this never results in anything bad does
it this never heads anywhere ugly does
it
when you take an entire portion of the
population
[Music]
and you turn them into the causes
of everything that ails us
by their very existence simply by
leaving the house they put you at risk
they're going to kill your kids that
doesn't lead anywhere ugly does it
historically
oh it works out fine
um
and what about this from the
post-millennial a photo from a pride
event in holland won an award for being
iconic
and the most aesthetic it shows a small
child smiling while surrounded by men in
bondage gear
you can see the picture there the men in
harnesses and shiny black hot pants are
gathered outdoors on a porch where a
little girl plays with a swing set the
post-millennial's andy noe shared the
photo saying that a woman claiming to be
the girl's mother
had opened her home for the men to
change
the photo was called celebrating
diversity
and was snapped by jan van breda
this photo from a pride of event holland
has won an award from the organizers for
being iconic yes this is iconic
aesthetic beautiful we're told
comfort ourselves by saying this is
holland over there in europe they're way
crazier than we are well no this is this
is this is already here as well all the
pieces are in place
i mean this is of course the outright
uh promotion of pedophilia
and all the places pieces are in place
in our culture as well
all the pieces are there because for one
thing we're saying
uh you know
we we have to be supporting and tolerant
of all different lifestyles
as long as it's
consensual we we have to support it and
we have to even not just not support it
or tolerate it but celebrate it
and that that thing of consent that was
the one thing
as i've said many times we've we've
hinged we've gotten rid of all
notions of sexual morality
the whole sexual moral code that has
guided most of mankind for millennia
we've tossed out the window but we have
hung on to this one thing the c word
consent
and that's all that matters
and we know that consent does matter it
is very important it is one of the
fundamental
um
you know moral prerequisites
but not the only one
and the thing is you don't
if
if we're talking about
love and devotion
and human dignity if we're bringing that
into the equation
with human sexual relations then we
don't even need to talk about consent
because that comes with
it we're throwing all that out who cares
about love cares about devotion who
cares about human dignity
none of that matters obviously these men
here they don't care about their own
dignity
a lot of times these pride events
celebrations of pride but also a
celebration of a lack of dignity
men walking around like that no shame
whatsoever a celebration of
shamelessness
so that all goes out the window the only
thing we have left left is consent
and i think most people assume or hope
that well because we have consent that's
going to stop
the train from going any further than it
already has gone uh because
children cannot consent to sexual
relations and so that's why we're not
going to see the normalization of
pedophilia yes that's true
but at the same time we're also being
told that children can decide their own
gender from the age of three
they can make these
uh kind of profound lifelong changes and
choices for themselves
choices that are not just lifelong and
profound but also that deal with their
sexuality
they are fully equipped at the age of
four to make those choices
to consent to those choices
it is not a far leap
before the people who are saying that
also say well
they can consent to change their gender
for
maybe they can also consent to sexual
relations
not a far leap we're already seeing that
start to happen and um
it will become more explicit in the
years ahead much sooner than i think
most people
realize all right let's move now to
reading the youtube comments uh this is
from the lonely dragon says you know
you've screwed up when you see when you
draw matt sweet baby gang walsh himself
to a public meeting to yell at actual
supposed humans well i don't think i
yelled at them did i yell a little bit
i was speaking forcefully
maybe lapsing into yelling i'll admit
um john says that was absolutely
flawless i've never been more proud to
be a member of the sweet baby gang than
i am now everybody give it up for the
sweet daddy walsh that's my sweet daddy
uh you know i this this sweet daddy
thing is
it is
i i hate to say it
maybe it's run its course i don't know
how much longer i can see because the
other problem is that
the comments that say things like this
that's my sweet daddy they're always fr
they're all they always have names like
john bill
hey sweet daddy
it is getting it's getting a little bit
disturbing but thanks for the support
anyway
um anna says thank you matt for giving
us the proof that you wear skinny jeans
stop that those were regular boot cut
jeans jeans okay that's it
let's start stop the skinny jean rumors
in its tracks right there
uh communist mal says those are the
skinniest genes i've ever seen on a dude
that's not true
i mean have you ever seen jeans on a
dude at all because those are normal
jeans the first time you ever seen a guy
wear jeans
let this not be the focus of the school
board speech okay
um
and
nathan says based on his fast-paced
raving and ranting i would offer a
diagnosis of my own especially in light
of his gleeful tone on how as a taxpayer
he's going to make sure that the captive
audience at the meetings will be forced
to listen to him many more times in the
future
narcissistic personality disorder is a
disorder in which a person has an
inflated sense of self importance
matt do you bring up the fact that no
one had died of cholera in years to rail
against hand washing policies do you
know how dry and damaged your skin gets
if you have to wash every time you go to
the bathroom and get dirty please come
after the true threats
okay nathan
uh uh so i'm gonna try this again here
okay
you say that
wearing a mask
is like washing your hands
a basic ordinary hygiene method right
that's the comparison you're making
okay
then nathan
why didn't you ever wear a mask until 18
months ago
i'm assuming you didn't um correct me if
i'm wrong maybe you're the one person in
america who actually did prior to 18
months ago walk around every day to mask
i'm going to assume
that you didn't
and now you're saying yeah it's just
like wearing a mask it's no big it's
just like washing your hands it's no big
deal
why didn't you do it before
did you not know that masks existed
did you not know that medical
professionals used them to you know stop
themselves from
spreading germs or coming in contact
with germs did you not know any of that
like is there anything that's happened
with masks in the last 18 months that
was really enlightening to you did you
learn anything about masks that you
didn't already know
because i i'm assuming that's not the
case either
so you knew the masks existed you you
knew what they did
what what uh service they are supposed
to perform
um yeah covet wasn't out there but you
knew that many other
pathogens and germs and so on were in
viruses were out there
airborne viruses the flu other things
many of those may not have been as
deadly to you as cova but they're still
out there
and you could get infected
and you say that wearing a mask is
nobody else like wash your answer why do
you do it
i'm not going to give you any i'm not
going to give your answer for you it's
not a rhetorical question i really want
to know
because i've been asking this question
for months and i can never get anyone to
answer it all the people who say wearing
a mask is no big deal it's the most
self-evident thing in the world of
course we should do it it stops us from
getting sick so and so forth why didn't
you do it before
give me an answer
and if you're going to tell me it's
because you didn't know basic facts
about mask before 18 months ago then
that means you're too stupid to take
seriously
if you give me any other answer then
it's going to seem like you're a
hypocrite so i think you're kind of in a
bind here but i'd love to see what the
answer is
um michael cash says does ben shapiro
have a new book out i watch you every
day just curious
i'm not sure but
let's find out right now
and it turns out yes ben shapiro does
have a book out right now it's called
the authoritarian moment and uh it is a
book that's uh
it could not possibly be more timely
especially as we
head back into lockdowns and mask
mandates and everything we know that
we're living in an authoritarian
hellscape but how do we get to this
point what do we do about it those are
the questions that benchmark tackles so
eloquently in the authoritarian moment
which is now available on amazon barnes
noble or any other major bookseller so
you go get your copy right now also
after you do that it's no secret that
candace owens knows how to light up
twitter with her conservative takes but
if you haven't heard she's now opening
her studio to one lucky vip winner if
you sign up now as a daily wire member
with code vip you'll get 25 off your new
membership and be automatically entered
for a chance to win a trip for two
for you and a guest to the daily wire
studios to see candace live not only
will you meet candace you'll get an
inside look at her studio front row
seats to watch her uh on her show
candace and it's just a great deal all
around so to take advantage of this
all you gotta do is become a new daily
wire member at dailywire.com subscribe
where you can use code vip and get 25
off which will automatically enter you
for a chance to win the vip experience
but wait
there's more we've got a lot to
celebrate here at the daily wire
including the success of our newest
podcast the morning wire intent on
supplying americans with a daily dose of
nothing but the facts that's been
topping the apple and spotify charts
since its recent release because it's
the only daily news podcast that values
your time and the truth and while we're
working over time to bring you the news
you need to know we need your help to
make sure this gets out to more and more
people so subscribe and start listening
now to morning morningwire on
applespotify or wherever you listen to
podcast and leave a five-star review if
you like what you hear and also no that
was just it okay we'll leave it there
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
yeah i read a book a few years ago by an
author by the name of bill bryson uh
excellent author excellent book it was
called in a sunburn country and it was
all about bryson's adventure down under
in australia uh he he describes a
somewhat wild unpredictable but
beautiful place full of
deadly dangers but also bold outgoing
and often quite fearless freedom-loving
people
over the last few weeks though you know
i've wondered
what an updated version of that book
might be given recent events
australia as you may have heard is in a
full lockdown because of coronavirus the
measure it has uh the measures taken are
among the most extreme in the world with
the military being called in to enforce
the rules in many of its cities
including in sydney which has had a
total of four cases
yes four
in a year okay four cases in a year and
the military shows up
in fact the whole country of 25 million
is experiencing a a rolling average of
two coveted deaths a day two a day now
if i were to venture to do some math
here which is usually a mistake by my by
my calculations a total of point zero
zero zero zero zero eight percent of the
population is dying of covett per day
and that is enough to justify a
military-enforced lockdown
and all of this while australia remains
a country absolutely chock-full
of scary deadly stuff that can kill you
there are more natural dangers in
australia than almost anywhere else on
earth outside of maybe the amazon
rainforest in fact covet has killed as
many people this year in australia as
animal attack attacks typically kill in
the same country
266 people were killed by animals in
australia between 2008 and 2017 making
about you know 25 or so a year
uh that's about how many have died from
kovat this year in australia
by the way most of the animal deaths are
from horses and cows surprisingly which
means that it's it's not far from the
truth to say that the average australian
should be about as afraid of livestock
as he is of covet
they might as well shut down the country
and and call in the military over a
loose cow roaming the streets somewhere
but don't expect the authorities in
charge of australia to have this sense
of proportion any more than the
authorities in charge of the rest of the
world have a sense of proportion here is
the health chief of new south wales dr
carrie chant
giving a master class in
disproportionate responses watch this
we all need to work together
we need to limit our movements
we need to consider whenever we leave
our house that anyone with us
anyone we come into contact with
could
convey the virus
so
whilst it is a human nature to engage in
conversation with others
to be friendly
unfortunately this is not the time to do
that so even if you run into your next
door neighbor
in the shopping center in the coles
whilst you're at kohlsworth's or aldi or
any other
grocery shop
don't start up a conversation
now is the time for minimizing your
interactions with others
even if you've got a mask
do not think that affords total
protection we want to be absolutely sure
that as we go about our daily lives we
do not come into contact with anyone
else that would pose a risk
the virus is out there anyone can have
it everyone is a threat everyone could
kill you do not engage not don't speak
to anyone don't have conversations a
conversation could kill you if your
neighbor tries to say hello shoot him in
the face
and then run and lock yourself in the
basement your lives depend on it
now i listen to that and um
you have to understand i am actually in
favor of banning small talk okay i'm in
favor of sending in the military to stop
people from having small talk
conversations i already do avoid having
interactions with people
i already have adopted a policy of using
lethal force on anyone who attempts to
have a conversation with me i already am
unfriendly
i already am a fascist dictator so
this should all be music to my ears
in fact i should be volunteering to go
to australia and use my expertise to
help enforce these rules but
avoiding conversation due to a generally
anti-social disposition
is far different from avoiding it due to
a suffocating fear that having a
conversation will literally kill you
i can understand and endorse the former
not the latter
but the scariest thing here as always
is not the insane rambling of dr chant
with the new south wales health office
there have always been power mad
sociopaths in position of power
inevitably those are the kinds of people
who typically seek positions of power
this is the case everywhere and for all
time which is why our system was was not
put in place to attract specially
virtuous politicians there is no such
thing but instead to protect us against
the megalomaniacal idiots who would
unavoidably end up in those positions
unfortunately
that system hasn't been working as well
in recent times and in any case that is
not what scares me the most in this case
what scares me are all the average
people
however many millions of them who do not
see any problem
with locking yourself away and avoiding
all human contact treating human beings
as plague carrying rodents for fear of a
virus that has infected four people in
your city in a year and killed none of
them
many millions in australia and here and
across the world have lost their ability
to think rationally about this or most
anything else
talking to them feels very much like
like the conversations i have with my
daughter when i've tried to convince her
that there's no monster in the closet
i mean her fear and her imagination
override any rational analysis or
investigation of the question which is
fine for an eight-year-old i i can
literally open the closet
and show her and say look see there's
nothing in here
okay just mounds of clothes on the floor
because you can't be bothered to hang
them properly as i've told you a million
times in fact you know what maybe there
are monsters under that mound of clothes
you know yeah yeah yeah hang the clothes
so that monsters don't hide under it how
about that
anyway we've gotten sidetracked but the
point is that children can be childish
in that way and that again is fine
it is not fine for grown adults
we live now in a world of adults
cowering in fear because of the monsters
in their closets and all of those adults
especially the ones running australia
are canceled in fact the whole country
of australia is cancelled if you people
want to be afraid of something be afraid
of the spiders in your country you have
spiders literally raining from the sky
threatening to crawl into your ears and
eat your brain that's a rational fear
focus on that instead
in the meantime
you're all canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producer is mathis glover
our technical directors austin stevens
production manager pablo vadosky
the show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by niko geneva and
our production coordinator is mckenna
waters the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily
dailywire 2021.
john bickley here daily wire
editor-in-chief wake up every morning
with our new show morning wire on
today's episode vaccine passports are on
the rise the showdown between texas
republicans and democrats heats up and
the california recall election tightens
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morningwire
[Music]